to some extent when people think about
the economy we tend to think about uber
and lyft but to me at least there is
endless opportunities in trying to match
between what people really want to do
and the people have true needs
rather than trying to just get into a
full employment model which is what we
do now where most of us the majority of
what we do is very limited in terms of
value in terms of the whole day so the
economy is of that's the idea if people
want to think about that
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders i'm so
excited for this episode because i have
my good friend god alone with me the
jeffrey a keswon professor and professor
of operations information and decisions
and the director of the management and
technology program at the university of
pennsylvania he is an award-winning
educator teaching courses on scaling
technology ventures and operations
strategy god's recent research primarily
considers gig workers quick decision
making and the communication between
firms and customers he is the co-founder
of four class helping professors drive
higher student engagement and
accountability in the classroom meet god
god alone professor galon welcome to 20
minute leaders thank you so much for
joining me how are you i'm good great to
be here michael
ghana i'm so happy that you're here and
i'm so excited to do this episode
together you are the professor of
operations information and decisions and
the director of the incredible m t
program of the university of
pennsylvania professor also at wharton
and a thought leader and everything that
comes to operations and scale and and i
have to sound a personal level i've been
learning so much from you over over the
last year and a half or so and and it's
such a true pleasure
and and i'm excited to pick your brain
now in 20 short minutes i'm not going to
be able to encapsulate nearly as much as
i want but but we're going to dive
straight into the point
tell me a little bit about what you what
do you work on what does it even mean to
concern yourself with the questions of
of operations information and scale yeah
that's a great question so a little bit
about myself originally from from israel
as you can get from the accent and from
the name i did my phd workforce israeli
startups in large scale databases phd at
columbia
11 years at kellogg and now it's wharton
at penn
as director of imagine technology but my
background is really in in very much two
adjacent areas on one side
a game theory and understanding economic
theory and at the same time
understanding cueing theory and
operational theory so i love what i do
whether it is related to scaling or
related to the gig economy that i want
to talk about in a second is really
about areas where you need to understand
not only
the nitty-gritty of processes but you
need to understand also how they
actually embed themselves within a
situation where you have different
decision-makers and potentially interact
among themselves so that stuff like the
intersection of these two can be
platforms can be supply chains and can
be the gay economy which is where i
spend a significant amount of time now
it sounds very simple of course and tell
me a little bit about about the gig
economy it's a it's a relatively new new
concept that you know is obviously
taking the world by a storm and not
nearly enough people are thinking
critically about it but luckily we have
the amazing god alone who is tell me
tell me about what the gig economy in
high level and then tell me a few a few
key concepts from their daily life yeah
so i think at a very high level um there
is really nothing new there at the very
high level this is just a marketplace
where people
think about freelancers existed forever
like since essentially the dawn of
civilization almost you had freelancers
um
what the gig economy brought and we said
gee economy people the name that come to
mind are of course uber and lyft but
also upwork and and the israeli fiber
and all the way to catalan and even
beyond that and and all of these are
essentially riding on the fact that all
of us have a mobile device or in front
of a laptop
and so continuously they're able to
match people have a need and the need
can be a ride it can be a piece of
software written can be
a a furniture being assembled if it's
taskrabbit and there is someone probably
around you
willing to do that when i say around you
it can be physical if it's an uber or
lyft or it can be someone in the other
parts of the world willing to write a
piece of software for you so give an
example you see this microphone here
when i started teaching
um i realized that i need to devote
develop new set of skills now to teach
online to very quickly realize i can get
a good camera and i can find that on
youtube and i can get many things but
once you get into a good microphone you
need to get
a you realize that the limits of what
you know is is is pretty low and and
i went on upwork and found a sound
engineer someone that is an actual
guitar player that lives in portland
um and you know i can spend hours on
that he spent years on that
so on a zoom call i took it it took me
five minutes to post it on upwork
five more minutes to interview three
people
five four minutes to schedule the call
and then we spend an hour where i have
an amplifier here and we optimize every
level of that now work on where i work
cannot employ a sound engineer they just
don't have the the interest on having
something like that for full time he
doesn't want to work with someone like
me he wants to work with rock bands
and and you know as as cool as i am as i
think i am i'm definitely not school as
cool as the people that you work with
usually and and so it's a that's to some
extent when people think about the
economy we tend to think about uber and
lyft but to me at least there is endless
opportunities in trying to match between
what people really want to do and the
people have true needs
rather than trying to just get into a
full employment model which is what we
do now where most of us the majority of
what we do is very limited in terms of
value in terms of the whole day so the
economy is of that's the idea if people
want to think about that and obviously
we've seen huge catalysts over the last
few years whether it's the the
globalization through the digital
digitalization the connectivity of the
entire world the global pandemic which
drove everything online and we're seeing
the entrance of billions of people into
workforce that that previously were much
less accessible but but you're also
picking up on some interesting trends
that you're observing now coming out of
the pandemic that that i think have have
really interesting insight so for
example drivers
right so one thing that both uber and
lyft are warning about and we are
cigarette if you try to to call an uber
over the last month you notice two
things you notice very high
prices significantly more usage of surge
pricing and also significant longer
waiting times
and not because of demand
and it is because of a combination of
two things right exactly so demand
actually has been going up but you know
not significantly the main thing is
indeed as you're saying it's really the
fact that drivers are reluctant to go
back to work and you know i've been
following this industry for a while so
when kovitz started last march
we noticed that actually the drivers
kept on driving
the
the decline was primarily in demand so
people didn't want to use uber people
didn't know i mean many places had
lockdowns more places stopped going to
the office so we saw a significant
decline in demand not so much a big
decline in
drivers but what we're seeing now is
actually we see the drivers are slower
to come back and then we when you ask
drivers why
they say to some extent one of the
interesting thing about the gig economy
is that
the firms don't employ these drivers
right that's a big debate around the
world whether they should employ them or
not or
like what's the right employment model
but they did not and so most of them say
most of these firms treated us the same
way that the cable firm
is is treating us you know they lure us
initially into the service they lock us
in the moment they're in they start
lowering down the incentives and
ultimately we end up with incentives
initially but now we're doing many short
rides
for very low price we've been to that
movie already
we don't want to go back so that's one
thing we definitely see we see people
questioning whether that's the right
employment model for them now that
they've seen it going once the second
thing we know
is that the gig economy
to summoning drivers has a very strong
and that's we've we've worked with the
firm and analyzed 8 000 drivers for a
whole year
and we noticed that drivers have a very
predictable behavior predictable in the
following way
the more you pay them the more likely
they are to drive so pay is important
and i'm sure no one is shocked by that
but the shocking part was the fact that
the longer they worked until now
the
more likely they are going to continue
to work while the more they earn until
now the less the less likely they're
going to work so basically what we're
going to we're seeing is significant
time-based inertia and that's
interesting primarily for two things
it's interesting because most of these
drivers actually when you ask them why
are they driving for uber or lyft they
say i want flexibility
but in fact when you see how they behave
flexibility is not what they look for
they look for
within that flexible world they look for
consistency and now that they're not on
the road they say actually maybe i don't
really need to go back
and that's basically it's a cold start
problem the question for the firms how
do we bring them back
the interesting thing here is
that and why i'm not very optimistic for
uber lyft specifically because it shows
you what's going to happen in the gay
economy in the future
you always have to compete both on the
demand side and the supply side
on the demand side that's clearly right
you don't always have to compete on us
as driver or as customers but most of us
use one service either uber or lyft or
door dash or caviar whatever we're using
but when it comes to drivers our data
shows that 40 of them multi-home
and to some extent that's what i find
really interesting in this new economy
is most of us when we decide on where to
work it's usually once a year
once in two years maybe once seven years
if you're in academia here you see
people that make
decisions almost every 15 minutes
wow and most of them are comparing and
again 40 of them within the same day
work for multiple firms
and so it really requires to rethink the
sort of a new type of labor economics to
try to understand and again i'm not just
interested in uber at least i'm
interested in the entire stack here
because over time
more more and more of our employment
model is going to move to senate look
like that and so i think there are many
many questions on that but but i think
you know our time is short so so i want
to make sure we devoted to the things
that are interesting for you i love the
extrapolation you're looking at a
specific case study that you're trying
to understand the the then the consumer
behavior the labor behavior of the
drivers and you're understanding okay
well actually there's there's a growing
trend here that is going all across the
stack of the labor market now before we
move on to the next thing what does this
actually mean to to the to the leaders
right so the people that are thinking
through these models it's not just about
how do i get people to buy into to buy
into my app and to order the uber but
now i actually have to cater to another
set of the marketplace and it's not as
simple as offering them more bent more
health benefits and a higher rate wages
right
so
that's a great question and there are
two things one is you we trained our
managers to think very much consumer
based so how do i think about my
consumers how do i think about my
employees
we have to find managers to just think
about the ecosystem how do i create
value in the ecosystem and the ecosystem
means that i'm primarily
creating interactions rather than the
ones that manage each and every aspect
of the relationship
that's one the second thing which i
think is even more important i think
managers of the future
will have to think about one of the main
capabilities they will have to have is
manage many stakeholders and manage many
different employees that are not your
employees
i think if you think about the in the
past you had you were a ceo you're the
ceo you had the vp and the entire stack
and you that each stage had the
hierarchy that they managed in the
future you'll have to think about how do
you bring the right because let's say
the best crypto expert might not be your
employees but you need them for five
minutes in a year and you will need to
know how to orchestrate that we need to
think about managers that don't think
about how to create hierarchies but how
do i bring the right person to the right
role at the right time
and how do i incentivize them how to
create the right structure how do i
motivate them maybe it's not about
incentivization maybe it's about
motivation to actually come there do the
best work and ultimately live only to
come back the year after that very
different employment model very
different way of thinking about firms i
don't think we're ready we're definitely
not training our managers to think like
that yet
way too many questions are coming up
but but really what i'm what i want to
use this time for is to understand a
little bit you better because a lot of
people are curious about these things
i'm deeply curious about these things
you can let me read articles day in and
day out
what does it take though god to become a
thought leader in this space which is
exactly where you were you embody what
what what type of thinking does it
require what is your day-to-day work
look like
yes that's a great question i i think to
some extent
um
what i think what makes for for a good
professor in an applied area right i
mean that people are doing so my area is
i call it applied theory right i look at
areas that requires to build theory but
they're very applied in the sense of
taking firms deeper into what they do
and
i think what really
makes
what was of what motivates me are
looking at problems that from from the
surface looks simple
right i mean you say well drivers don't
show up to work and i start getting
deeper and deeper and deeper and i try
to build very rigorous models
that
really look at each and every driver and
you look at our models that we build
these are very complex models that look
probabilistically at how people are
moving from places and but the point
here is that you take that is very
strategic and simple and you dive deeper
and deeper and deeper and to really
build new theory of how these drivers
think and how
callers think in a call center and how
managers think in a supply chain i don't
want to say all of these are similar but
all of them are similar in a sense that
you're really getting to that to mystic
level and trying to understand them only
then to take that and use that to try to
explain data and use it to go up
and one thing i enjoyed doing more and
more in the last year or so is to write
my newsletter where i try to take
exactly these ideas and boil them down
to something
that i can explain in thousand words to
someone that is not in the classroom
that is not an expert in research and
what i've seen is that the ability on
one side to write a very rigorous paper
but at the same time to write a fairly
broad audience a a stuff like newsletter
there is a very strong relationship
between them in the ability to
crystallize and make the
the question clear take the observation
and make them clear but then that
actually initiates a new set of
questions that's what academia is it's
the it's the
constant
question of every question as you said
raises a set of a whole set of questions
and and if you're if you like that life
of every time finding more questions
than answers academia is a perfect life
for you
does this
rigorous way of thinking of problems day
in and day out real world problems that
are presented every day you you
mentioned to me that you're ordering an
uber and you're wondering to yourself
why is it taking longer now than before
does this change the way that you that
your relationship with the world or the
your daily life in general do you do you
see yourself evolving your your
questioning also on just regular
everyday things that aren't connected
necessarily to the research that you're
doing
so that's yes it's so i i tell this i
tell my students that
after taking my course
there will be a new set of questions
that will always ask themselves they
will not become happier people but they
will become more informed people and
then to some extent that's the issue
right i mean that you start seeing a
queue everywhere you go you start seeing
inefficiency everywhere you go um
ultimately you have to try to get away
from that but that's to some extent
really i think
that
i i i leave my research and many of my
questions started from i'll give you
just like one example
i i wrote i started the paper a few
years ago i was invited by an and an
israeli club to give a talk on how is my
research relevant to israel and my point
was that it's actually not relevant i do
work on queueing but queuing are
the same queues are the same in israel
and everywhere else but they gave a few
examples where accusers are different in
israel on the fact that people
tend to short to to always cut the line
that there is always coming and saying i
only have a question
and it was a half joke but then i took
that joke and wrote a very rigorous
paper about a repeated game theory model
where people come with different
requests and build a community and
discuss the size of the community and
one of my most fun papers to write
a with an economist in fact was exactly
about this topic so many times something
that even you don't think that actually
worth a paper once you go deeper into
that you realize hey there is a really
interesting question here why cues are
different in france versus the uk
where's the culture coming where's the
size of the community where all of these
coming so to me it's like i leave my
research day to day and i take my
experiences and try to inform the way i
think about research
amazing i love it god i really want to
thank you for coming the 20 minutes go
by way way too fast i still have a
couple more questions a little bit more
digging into your past and and i want
you to take me back to your childhood
before your your professor of operations
and queueing and scaling the thought
leader i want you to take me back to you
know middle school
how what is your childhood like what
what really fascinates you as you're
going about your life
yes so i you know i talked about
software and and
i was fascinated with software from a
very very young age i had a a sinclair
computer at a a i work with on a
commodore when we still had cassettes um
so i programmed since i saw since i was
very very young i tell kids sometimes or
people that apply to college that i'm
not impressed if you send me a mock-up
because when i was
eight i already wrote my first code and
i didn't have google or or stack
overflow to go and take the code for
actually i had to write it from a book
line by line so software always
fascinated me um and to this day by the
way i still like to take a new language
every summer and learn how to code so in
that sense i think while
that's not what i do full-time that's
the notion of building software and
building things is still something that
fascinates me to this day but that's i i
remember my my first memories are
exactly about this
so you're we're you're working on a lot
of fascinating things but but what
really inspires you
either professionally or personally as
you go about your life right now
yeah so so that's like
we're recording that in the summer and
every summer i choose two topics to to
study uh and so this summer i chose
solidity
ethereum as a way to try to program my
first nft so at the end of the summer i
left my first nft that i programmed
myself and the second one i usually pick
a philosopher to go deeper into that and
this summer is hegel so every summer i
choose one very underground topic and
one very ambitious topic and ultimately
at the end of the summer i come a little
bit more informed not very informed but
dangerous enough to actually talk about
that without actually knowing too much
about that so every summer i try to
reignite this process because
when you're in school you learn just by
osmosis sometimes you i mean you get
things to do and you learn once you're
beyond that you need to create a system
that continuously takes you outside your
comfort zone and much of blockchain is
going to be important but
i can how can i talk about unless i
actually try to do something within that
i'm not an expert in epistemology but i
try to to write about discussion boards
so i need to understand better these
topics so that's of like the constant
idea of trying to infuse new ideas this
time that going back to my a middle
school experience very much stays until
today never born conversation with you
trust me and god what are three words
that you would use to describe yourself
yeah so this is some of the things we
discussed already so i think the first
thing is rigorous i i whenever i write
something whenever i do anything i need
to make sure that it's rigorous
i
feel strongly about being applied so i i
like things that have impact on real
people
and the last one is integrity i like
things that integrate things from
different areas i discuss game theory
and in in queueing theory but almost
everything that they do has an
integration so rigorous
integration and applied are sort of like
my three main
ideas that when i think about the new
project what do i want to do they should
be there
god thank you so much this was uh so
enjoyable and and interesting
and and i'm gonna adopt some of some of
the habits that you mentioned because i
think that they're you know i can i can
feel the curiosity just emerging through
this conversation here and i just love
it thank you for the inspiration and
stay safe and stay healthy no michael
great to be here
you